welcome to another Dr Sadler's honest
book review the book that I have here
today is a very recent one from 2023
called the essential stoic the most
important writings from the masters of
stoicism and it's officially copyrighted
interestingly to Mark Tweeter who wrote
the forward or introduction which we'll
talk about in a moment I'm going to
begin by saying that this is going to be
a little bit of an unusual review
because usually I have a lot of positive
things and not too many negative things
to say it's going to be quite the
opposite for this one so buckle in
because we got a lot of interesting
things to say
coming I like to begin these reviews in
a rather straightforward matter of fact
neutral Way by talking about the three
s's style structure summary let's begin
with the last one first so they build
themselves as the essential stoic the
people who put this book together
Anonymous editors of some sort the most
important writings from the masters of
stoicism a big claim we'll assess that
in just a
moment and you see you know Marcus
relius epic epicus and Sena depicted on
the front as well so you know if you're
into stoicism those are in fact three
really important authors that would
raise your hopes that what we're going
to see here is a very judicious and
wellth thought out selection of
important passages or even works by
these thinkers now uh let's talk about
structure so so what we have here is an
introduction it's actually listed on the
the front as forward which is it h you
know you decide by Mark Tweeter who is a
former athlete and the introduction is
less than two full pages long then we
immediately jump into Marcus aurelius's
meditations translated by George long
edited by Edwin gin in this case and
we'll talk about the significance of
that in a moment um I I do want to
signal that what we've got here is first
a preface and then a biographical sketch
of Marcus aelius and then a a little
philosophy of Marcus orelias so that
would you know lead you to think okay
what we've got here is the text and then
some commentary on it some introductory
materials jumping ahead to the next
section what we have is the
golden sayings translated by Hastings
Crossley of epicus and what we've get
there is two sections and then fragments
of epicus and then the hymn of cleanthes
and then finally we finish up with uh
senica's letters collected letters
translated by Richard matg an old
translation um and you know what we get
in each of these sections except for the
golden sayings is not the fullness of
the text but rather a selection not all
the meditations is contained in this
definitely not all of senica's letters
just by comparison here's a more recent
addition which you know granted is
slightly larger print but this gives you
an idea of how much of senica's letters
there are you can compare it to this
work right here so what about the style
here's where we get into the let's say
Providence of these texts what you're
going to notice as you read all of them
is that the style is rather old fashiony
why because these are all older
translations and why are they older
translations because uh whoever decided
to put this book together took
everything entirely from the public
domain and I would actually guess
certainly with the Marcus Aurelius and
with the epitus right from Project
gutenberg's public domain texts of these
these thinkers in their their same
translation so just to give you an idea
gin is writing this stuff in
1893 right um the biographical sketch
you just put it into Google it'll pop up
and it's coming straight from Project
Gutenberg so all they really did is copy
and paste from the internet into these
texts G available online as well you
know a little bit more recent
translation but not that recent over if
I remember right a 100 years old which
is why it was available for free so that
tells you about you know those three s's
with respect to this
book
I usually spend the bulk of these
reviews talking about the main points
that are made in the work this is not an
original work except in one respect the
very first part of it the one and two3
Page written by Mark Tweeter which I'll
read to you in just a moment if you've
read senica if you've read Marcus
arelius if you've read epicus you know
what points they're making about
stoicism you can easily do so online
simply by going to Project Gutenberg or
wikitext or pereus project or what
wherever you would like to you don't
have to get them from this book and I
don't think there's any point in me
spending our valuable time summarizing
basic doctrines of stoicism which you
can easily find yourself online I will
however read to you the one part of the
book actually two parts of the book
which are original so the introduction
by Mark Tweeter and why am I reading
this to you uh because it's interesting
to see what this uh person has to say
and because then you don't have to
wonder what's in this book that you
might be missing out on so
verbatim going through the most
challenging and trying moments in our
lives we seek support Sage advice and
inspiring quote or a beautiful Insight
that can give you Direction when you are
at a loss for where to go I was looking
for support when I was an athlete at the
Olympics the pressure of Performing
weighs heavily especially knowing how
much energy it takes to get to the games
my challenge was to maintain mental calm
In the Heat of the Moment I found the
answers to my challenge in the text
bundled in this book I found them in
senica's wise counsel he stood by me
with his words like a good friend and in
Marcus aurelius's deep musings on
leadership and epictetus's clear and
strict principles
PS my big dream was to become an Olympic
champion I could only achieve that goal
if I stopped being distracted by the
thought of gold and focused on my own
character values I needed the discipline
to work hard and deliver quality I
needed the courage not to let the fear
of failure consume me I pursue Justice
and wisdom to make the right choices
respect my opponents and pay attention
to my colleagues and others around me
the stoics lowercase s stoics say that
you should follow these character values
in your life I apply stoic lar uppercase
s philosophy as a guide a thought system
to counterbalance inevitable setbacks
and unpredictability in my life it helps
give direction to my dreams and
Ambitions and keeps me on the right
track I would like to briefly highlight
an example I blamed my father for my
parents nasty divorce I was especially
angry with him and had no contact with
him for years thanks to the teachings of
epicus I understood that my tendency to
judge was the s of my anger I learned
that my anger was not caused by my
father but by my conception of what a
good father should be that thought
liberated me I sought contact with him
again and gradually my anger dissipated
it is exactly what the stoics lowercase
s mean by finding Peace of Mind in an
important part of my life I found peace
instead of anger it enriched my life and
in the process enabled me to perform
better as an athlete a few months after
reconnect acting with my father in 2010
I won the 1500 meter gold medal at the
speed skating event in Vancouver and who
cheered loudest of all in the stands my
father since I stopped being a
professional athlete the lowercase s
stoic lessons have helped me in many
roles in my life as an entrepreneur son
father husband friend associate or
colleague Marcus aelius taught me I
should always keep my guiding principles
in mind and that the autonomy I pursue
will never lead to a worthwhile life it
if if it is not accompanied by a deep
human connection to others life is a
team sport senica taught me to be less
strict with myself he speaks beautifully
and wisely to me as a writer and teaches
me to guard myself against setbacks in
the opinions of others it gave me as an
anchor when as an entrepreneur I saw my
business almost collapse during the
Corona virus pandemic because of
disrupted production
chains with my performance Drive
ambition and my will to win I may not
naturally be a lowercase s stoic but
this is precisely why I try to apply
this mindset to my professional career
it allows me to find the right mental
balance sharp and relaxed wanting to win
gold but not focusing on gold every day
we can choose to live a good life be a
good person and do what is right to
achieve that we should not sit back but
act we can chat about it but actions are
the real test of character a good life
must be lived and lessons must be
applied this is why uppercase s stoic
philosophy appeals to me so much the
lowercase s stoics are not armchair
philosophers they are the people who
test and adjust their ideas in the real
world to pursue a better life for
themselves and others everyone deserves
the lessons described in these Timeless
and unique Works they have been an
important foundation of my happiness for
over 20 years they are the lessons I
draw on daily not life hacks or easy
tricks but deep life lessons that
require attention reflection and above
all action to come to life day in day
out there you have it that is the one
original piece of writing in this volume
uh the introduction by Mark Tweeter
there is something that is semi-original
on the back right the blurb um and this
might be helpful to bring
up discover the most important writings
from the three pillars of stoicism
bringing together the essential writings
of the three most influential stoic
philosophers the essential stoic is an
accessible and instructive guide To
Living a better life through the
teachings of stoicism distilling the
wisdom of the stoic Masters this volume
contains the three most widely read
volumes of stoic philosophy and history
as well as an insightful introduction
from Olympic gold medalist and
best-selling author Mark Tweeter readers
will get a
comprehensive 360 degree view of
stoicism M from epictetus's ethics to
Marcus aurelius's Reflections to
senica's aphorisms the philosophers
combined wisdom shows readers how to
live their best lives staying calm and
rational in the face of hardship
remaining true to their own code of
ethics and accepting the world on its
own terms so uh that's it for the main
points that's what uh this purports to
provide you with and now you know what
Mark Tweeter has to say anything else
you can find in the the freely available
public domain texts on stoicism or
summarizing stoicism which were compiled
into this
volume I always try to have some good
things to say about a text in many cases
it's really easy to go on and on about
what I liked about a particular text in
this case I will say this it was kind of
nice to read Mark tweeter's uh short
little uh personal
reflection um and the cover design ain't
bad you know uh the only thing that I
would say is wrong with the cover is the
title The Essential stoic and the
subtitle the most important writings
from the masters of stoicism but it does
have a nice design and they did pick
some decent images for each of the three
authors whose public domain Works they
have reproduced in this
volume what did I find problematic about
this work well actually quite a lot
let's start with the price on the back
us $20 Canada $27 seems a lot to pay for
Texs that are completely available with
the one exception of the less than two
page introd production by Mar Mark
Tweeter completely free to you in many
places online that's a problem I I think
that it's unethical to be bundling
together texts like this and not
providing any I mean there there is a
little bit of introduction and summary
of Marcus aelius all of that is
available online for free to you as well
and it's outdated these translations are
using oldfashioned language that a lot
of readers are not going to find
particularly helpful so I I I think it's
unconscionable to publish something like
this from a major publisher like St
Martin's press which is owned by
McMillan um it seems just basically a
cash grab and so I have a problem with
that myself I think that that it's
particularly egregious when you're
talking about ethics and stoicism to do
do something that stoic authors the
three that are pictured here would
themselves have some serious problems
with so that that's point one um the
selections are not the best so I'm going
to start with the elephant in the room
the golden sayings of
epicus not what you would want if there
was going to be one text by epicus that
should go into something called the
essential stoic it's the enidan the one
text that has been used for Millennia
how old is the golden
says uh a little over a hundred years
old this guy uh who translated it um
Hastings uh he he just put together a
jumble of excerpts drawn from the
enidan and from the discourses the much
longer more systematic teachings of
epicus and translated it in a thei sort
of way you know that is not particular
ly faithful as far as translations not
organized and published it as a book and
since it became public domain there's
lots of republication of this but if
you're seriously going to study
epicus enidan discourses those are your
texts not the golden sayings as a matter
of fact that's the sign of an amateur
that you look to the golden sayings the
golden sayings also include these
fragments fragments are not what you
ought to be studying we don't even know
if these came from epicus I mean we're
reasonably sure that the discourses in
the nidian they're from one of his
students a lot of these
fragments they're you know if they're in
a a critical Edition you have something
like so and so said that epicus said
this but we don't know that that's the
case so to present that as if it's
somehow epictetus's teachings again
untruthful
unethical even with the selections from
Marcus aurelius's meditation and Sen's
letters okay so there's some good stuff
in there and then there's other stuff
where you're like well why did they
leave this out and why did they put this
stuff in there there is zero discussion
other than perhaps you know the hint
that by Mark Tweeter maybe he put them
together or maybe it was some unknown
editor in in uh McMillan's offices why
they picked the particular passages from
these texts and so they do not live up
to the most important writings I mean
senica's letters are important Marcus
aurelius's meditations are important the
golden sayings not important should have
been the discourses in idian but in the
letters in the meditations is this a
selection of the most important writings
it's not so you'd be better off reading
other you know excerpted texts or
actually reading the whole thing Marcus
aurelius's meditations aren't really
that long
um
what else can can we say about this well
there were there were a few things from
the back that I wanted to bring up so
telling people that you're going to get
a comprehensive 360 degree view of
stoicism is just blatantly false you are
not going to get anything remotely like
that and you wouldn't get a
comprehensive 360 degree uh view on
stoicism if all you did was read Marcus
aurelius's meditations senica's letters
and pius's discourses and and cidian
because there's other works on stoicism
that we actually study senica wrote a
whole bunch of other works that are very
important we have cisero we have uh two
important summaries of stoic Doctrine
one from Aras dimus one from diagen IRAs
we have Heracles writings as well we
have musonius rufus's lectures right so
you're not going to get anything I I
wouldn't even say you're going to get a
90 degree vision of stoicism which at
least is corresponding to our our human
vision and uh okay epicus does talk
about ethics that's true Marcus Aurelius
Reflections that's true senica's
aphorisms senica writes letters one of
the letters that he actually writes is
about why aphorisms or maxims don't do
the job that people think that they they
should be doing right and interestingly
that one is in here on the futility of
learning maxims so they're not even
consistent between their the things that
they selected and probably didn't read
and what they're saying about this book
on the back so you know this is this is
really quite a a problematic thing now I
will close by saying U I don't have any
problem with the introduction it's a
nice little reflective piece about how
an athlete found sto ISM useful I mean
it would be nice to see some consistency
between uppercase s and lowercase s in
this uh but that's that's a problem for
the editors not for that
writer all right final thoughts I think
you can tell if you've watched all the
way through to this point I am not a fan
of this book if there's anything that's
the diametric opposite of a book
recommendation I am giving that to you
right now this is not worth purchasing
it was not worth publishing the only
thing in it that's original at all is
this you know one and 3/4 or 2/3 page
little Reflection by uh Mark Tweeter um
so I I don't think that um that could
have been a blog post right and for all
I know may as well be a blog post out
there on the internet so I do not
recommend this and I've told you why and
now you know for warned is for
armed